[Musique]
l'histoire a retenu son trésor et son
cryptogramme bon le cryptogramme relève
plus du folklore réduite mais c'est vrai
que c'est un trésor exceptionnel et je
pense aussi qu'on peut retenir que c'est
un pirate qui vient de calais qu'a connu
les caraïbes le fameux pirates des
caraïbes qui sont les plus importants
dans l'imaginaire et dans l'histoire
faut le dire
il a connu aussi le golfe de guinée
l'afrique où il a pas mal piratés et
ensuite l'océan indien en finale mais il
a connu les trois grands théâtres de la
piraterie
moi je pense qu'on peut dire que c'est
un grand pirate au sens du palmarès ici
je peux dire ça reste évidemment un
bandit mais il a écumé tous les fins
plusieurs hausses ayant il a fait
peut-être une centaine de prises donc
c'est assez considérable la piraterie
c'est quelque chose que beaucoup de
dessinateurs
m aussi parce que celle aventure c'est
une époque c'est une histoire de cape et
d'épée en fait à l'appel de l'aventuré
l'appel piraterie n'a intéressé en fait
le trésor de la buse s'adresse aux
enfants à partir de 5 6 7 ans et l'idée
c'est aussi que grâce à la richesse des
dessins que l'enfant puisse évidemment
le relire plusieurs fois mais aussi que
les parents peuvent en le lisant
apprendre des choses et puis
s'émerveiller comme les nous on a pu
s'émerveiller sur ce monde des pirates
quand on était
quand on était enfant
le but c'était de
de trouver un style qui soit semi
réaliste en fait c'est à dire que de
garder ce côté un petit peu
je tairai 10 néant pour pour les enfants
et en sympathique attrayant tout en
gardant quelque chose qui fasse
suffisamment précis et réaliste pour le
côté historique en fait
[Musique]